stell dir vor du müsstest ein
schreckliches waffengesetz verteidigen
und dürfte dabei nicht einmal lügen wie
stellst du das an
nun wenn du das florida department of
law enforcement bist dann machst du das
wahrscheinlich auf diese clevere art und
weise ich hier
denn obwohl es nach dem waffengesetz
stent hugh grant 2005 mehr morde gab
sieht es so aus als würden die zahlen
fallen und die grafik ist nicht einmal
falsch sie ist nur sehr sehr irreführend
das fertigen und verstehen von
statistiken gefüllt ganze studiengänge
und nicht umsonst ist es der albtraum
vieler angehender soziologen psychologen
und wirtschaftswissenschaftler
statistiken zu verstehen ist schwierig
vor allem wenn sie das versuchen
anzüglichen mit welchen strategien
grafiken wie diese hier versuchen in die
wahrheit zu verzerren und wir gerade
jetzt während der aktuellen
berichterstattung fakt von fake
unterscheiden könnte das erfahrt ihr
heute bei doktor watson und vergesst
nicht den kanal zu abonnieren um kein
neues video zu verpassen
an dieser stelle muss ich erst mal
klarstellen dass eine statistik uns erst
einmal nichts böses will
allerhöchstens der autor der statistik
und selbst hier arbeitet der großteil
der forscher und wissenschaftler
gewissenhaft und richtig die gefahr gibt
oft in der darstellung und
weiterverwendung von statistiken ein
beispiel
gehen wir mal davon aus dass jeden monat
einer von einem millionen bürgern vom
blitz getroffen wird
das macht also 0,0001 prozent pro eine
millionen diesem monat wurde jetzt aber
pro einer million bürger zwei menschen
vom blitz getroffen also 0,0002 prozent
wie würdet ihr diese veränderung
beschreiben haben sie blitz panik
sollten sie haben mehr leute wurden vom
blitz getroffen
panikartig bitte haben sie panik meine
damen und herren oder 0,1 prozent mehr
plätze als letzten monat absolut kein
grund zur sorge
alles im normalen bereich welche dieser
beiden headlines informiert die leser
besser beide sind nämlich erst einmal
richtig
okay das ist natürlich nur ein fiktives
beispiel aber auch bei größeren werten
als eins oder zwei kann es zu
irreführenden schlussfolgerungen kommen
denn tatsächlich ist genau das schon
einmal so passiert nicht mit
blitzeinschlägen sondern mit
verhütungsmitteln
1995 hatte das britische komitee
zuständig für die sicherheit von
medikamenten eine warnung veröffentlicht
eine neue version der antibabypille soll
doppelt so großes thromboserisiko haben
wie ihr vorgänger
zwischen 1995 und 1996 wurde nämlich
eine reihe von studien veröffentlicht
konkret wurde hier eine neue generation
der pille mit der alten generation
verglichen
laut diesen studien sind bei der
früheren version der pille 1,6 von
10.000 frauen an thrombose erkrankt bei
der neuen version lag der wert zwischen
2,8 und 2,9
diese ergebnisse sind durch die
zeitungen das radio und das fernsehen
gegangen
hier hat man regelmäßig von einem tumult
in kriens also einer zweifachen erhöhung
gesprochen
das hat wiederum dazu geführt dass viele
frauen aufgehört haben die pille zu
nehmen
bei den unter 16 jährigen ist der anteil
von 40 auf 27 prozent gesunken und das
britische energie hat später einen
starken anstieg von abtreibungen
angenehm natürlich bleibt es jedem
selber überlassen welches risiko zu viel
wird trotzdem wurde den autoren der
studie
den regierungsbeamten und den
journalisten vorgeworfen die ergebnisse
der studie künstlich hochgespielt zu
haben
unter experten gelten diese warnungen
heute als der pilz g von 1995 und andere
studien haben später sogar
herausgefunden dass es nicht mal einen
nennenswerten anstieg von risiken von
pele 12 gegeben haben soll
einerseits wurde also nicht nur
übertrieben sondern andererseits wohl
auch einfach unsauber gearbeitet
trotzdem zeigt der pilz sehr gut wie die
darstellung von statistiken zu großer
verwirrung führen kann
mini fiel auf instagram unterwegs seid
dann habt ihr bestimmt schon mal so ein
bild hier gesehen
je gebildeter und erfolgreicher eine
frau ist desto mehr alkohol wird
getrunken und menschen die häufiger
fluren sind angeblich ehrlicher und
loyaler solche fakten sollten auf jeden
fall misstrauisch machen denn hier wird
oft ein zusammenhang hergestellt wo
wahrscheinlich gar keiner ist
auch hierzu ein kurzes beispiel wir
können davon ausgehen dass jedes jahr
sehr viele menschen in einem bett
sterben wenn wir jetzt einfach anfangen
würden nicht mehr in betten zu schlafen
könnten wir dann menschenleben retten
natürlich nicht sei es im krankenhaus an
den folgen einer verletzung oder im
eigenen bett an altersschwäche ohnehin
geschwächte oder verletzte menschen
müssen meistens liegen und versterben
dann leider im bett das bett selber hat
damit aber wenig zu tun
außerdem verbringen wir jeden tag
mehrere stunden im bett beim schlafen
und haben auch da eine
wahrscheinlichkeit zu sterben bevor wir
jetzt aber einen zusammenhang zwischen
den toden und dem bett herstellen müssen
wir unterscheiden zwischen korrelation
und kausalität korrelation bedeutet dass
es anzeichen dafür gibt dass zwischen
zwei variablen ein zusammenhang besteht
kein beweis eine kausalität bedeutet das
eine variable erwiesenermaßen eine
andere variable verändert bei den betten
handelt es sich um eine korrelation
richtig formuliert wäre es also kranke
menschen sterben tendenziell in einem
bett würden wir hier fälschlicherweise
aus diesen daten eine kausalität
feststellen würde es heißen kranke
menschen sterben weil sie in
einem bett liegen und wenn man sich mal
auf die suche begibt dann findet man
verdammt komische korrelationen die ganz
gut zeigen dass nur weil sich zwei
variablen ähneln das noch lange nicht
bedeutet dass ein zusammenhang besteht
hier sieht man zum beispiel eine grafik
gezeigt dass die anzahl der menschen die
zwischen 1999 und 2009 in einem
swimmingpool ertrunken sind mit in der
anzahl an filmen korreliert in denen
nicolas cage mitspielt oder dass das
einkommen von spielhallen fast genau so
verläuft wie die anzahl der vergebenen
doktortitel in computerwissenschaften
müssen wir also alle mehr zocken um
schlauer zu werden leider nicht all
diese variablen haben natürlich nichts
miteinander zu tun
sie korrelieren aber ein faktor
beeinflusst nicht den anderen
übrigens wenn ihr auf der suche nach gut
recherchierten science news auf
instagram seid dann folgt uns gerne auf
instagram patch doktor watson wir
recherchieren die fakten die wir jeden
tag posten vorher gründlich und ziehen
keine voreiligen schlüsse und außerdem
posten wir nicht nur einen irreführenden
satz sondern tatsächlich relativ lange
texte die gut recherchiert sind also
folgt uns da gerne um jeden tag ein
bisschen smarter zu werden ex doktor
watson
manchmal scheinen zwei variablen
allerdings so nah beieinander zu sein
dass es uns schwerfällt keinen
zusammenhang zu schließen
oft hat das damit zu tun dass wir einen
dritten faktor übersehen das nennt sich
fort course verlässt ihn mit einem
anstieg der weltweiten co2 emissionen
ist der anteil von übergewichtigen
menschen in der bevölkerung nach oben
geschossen
heißt das dass uns co2 dick macht
wahrscheinlich nicht aber eine
wohlhabende bevölkerung die mehr
konsumiert ist womöglich für beides
verantwortlich denn mehr reichtum
bedeutet mehr konsum der konsum von
energie und autos aber auch einfach mehr
konsum
oft wird die kausalität bei zwei
variablen aber auch fälschlicherweise
umgekehrt ein bekanntes beispiel dafür
ist kinder die brutale spiele spielen
werden selber gewalttätig was aber wenn
ohnehin schon gewaltige kinder wegen
ihrer aggressiven natur gerne
videospiele spielen die brutal sind also
genau umgekehrt es gibt super viele
möglichkeiten mit daten falsche schlüsse
zu ziehen und in die welt zu tragen
auch bei der visuellen darstellung lohnt
es sich kritisch zu bleiben kommen wir
dafür mal zurück zu der grafik vom
anfang des videos 2014 wurde im us
bundesstaat florida das take your brand
heiß diskutiert konkret handelt es sich
hierbei um ein gesetz zur
selbstverteidigung welches einem bürger
erlaubt tödliche gewalt zum selbstschutz
einzusetzen nicht lange hatte es
gedauert bis eine reihe von zeitungen
darüber berichtet haben dass die
todeszahlen durch schusswaffen mit der
einführung des gesetzes gesunden sein
sollen berufen würde sich da vor allem
auf diese grafik hier mag auf den ersten
blick auch so aussehen ist aber totaler
quatsch
denn die y achse wurde einfach auf den
kopf gestellt die erhobenen zahlen haben
gezeigt dass mit dem neuen gesetz die
morde sehr stark gestiegen sind wie ist
auch zu erwarten wäre
aber die grafik zeigt genau das
gegenteil trotzdem ist diese darstellung
an und für sich nicht falsch die daten
sind so richtig auch das links 873 und
rechts 7 121 fälle hervorgehoben wurden
ist nicht falsch aber es ist schwierig
nicht zusehen dass uns jemand hier
täuschen wollte
schaut mal da die zahlen sind insgesamt
runtergegangen und die kurve geht auch
runter es gibt zwar kein beweis dafür
dass diese grafik extra so aufgestellt
wurde aber an zufall glaube ich
persönlich nicht ein weiterer trick mit
der y achse ist sie nicht bei null
starten zu lassen
hier wird der sprung von 35 auf 39,6
prozent viel größer dargestellt als er
eigentlich ist da die y-achse nur werte
von 34 bis 42 prozent darstellt das soll
allerdings nicht heißen dass es verboten
ist eine y achse nicht bei null starten
zu lassen denn tatsächlich kann das
ziemlich nützlich sagen je nachdem
welche entwicklungen wir beschreiben
wollen
der globale finanzmarkt ist zum beispiel
extrem empfindlich und schon
vermeintlich kleine entwicklungen können
große auswirkungen haben
dieses beispiel von 2015 zeit ganz gut
wie eine y achse die mit null beginnt zu
wenig informationen gibt im vergleich zu
einer grafik die eben nicht bei null
beginnt ein anderes beispiel ist das co2
in unserer atmosphäre
denn wenn wir darüber sprechen geht es
um kleinste unterschiede die trotzdem
sehr große auswirkungen haben können
würde dieser graf die bei null starten
dann würde man diese schwanken denn hier
nicht mehr erkennen können wie bei
vielen dieser strategien kommt es also
auch hier auf den kontext an ein und
dieselbe modifikation eines graphen kann
in einem moment instrumentalisiert
werden um uns zu täuschen wären sie uns
im nächsten moment überhaupt erst das
nötige verständnis dafür gibt was die
zahlen wirklich zu bedeuten haben
für all diese beispiele gilt dass man
gewollte oder ungewollte
missverständnisse aus dem weg räumen
kann wenn man sich die daten mal genau
anschaut
denn der beste schutz vor
fehlinformationen ist neugierig bleiben
am besten vertrauen wir keine headline
die uns komisch vorkommt sondern schauen
uns die zugrundeliegenden studien mal
genauer an
dort finden wir dann heraus ob es
explizit die kausalität zwischen zwei
faktoren gibt oder ob hier entwicklungen
künstlich hochgespielt werden
hier ist es wichtig ein gefühl dafür zu
entwickeln welche studien
vertrauenswürdig sind ein indikator dass
eine studie wissenschaftlich anerkannt
ist ist das ipi reviewed wurde also von
anderen wissenschaftlern geprüft wurde
selbst wenn eine studie vertrauenswürdig
ist fehlt uns nämlich für manche
statistiken einfach das fachwissen
man muss sich intensiv mit studien und
ihren aussagen beschäftigen um zu
verstehen was die daten wirklich sagen
das kann ich ganz schön zeit und auch
gehirnschmalz in anspruch nehmen was
sind die komischen statistiken vor dem
ihr je gehört habe
schreibt mir das gerne mal in die
kommentare ich bin sehr gespannt was
euch da über den weg gelaufen ist meine
lieblings statistik hat gezeigt dass ihr
diesen kanal mit einem abo unterstützen
könnt um uns zu helfen mehr videos zu
machen und leuten den doktor watson auf
youtube gefällt gefällt auch doktor
watson auf instagram auch das ist eine
kausalität die video beweisen konnten
schaut mal vorbei wir posten wie gesagt
jeden tag einen spannenden fakt auf
instagram bin jeden tag ein bisschen
smarter werden also folgt uns da gerne
ansonsten wie immer bleibt neugierig
bleibt gesund